foreign
in Pittsburgh what's up Caitlyn
hey John what's up yeah I'm just
um yeah I just have a question for you
so well cool bring it on I'm I'm just
trying to get through the call right now
so
it's trying to get through the cold
I'm trying to get through this call
without my body taking off on me so yeah
I got you I got you okay all right hey
do me a favor okay
um take the deep as deep a breath as you
possibly can and hold it all right okay
do it real quick take it real deep
hold it one
two
three blow it out as hard as you can
okay and then your shoulders are up as
tight as they can be around your ears
drop them pull your hands down as far as
you can to the floor okay
okay cool now we're in it so what's up
thank you thank you
so beginning of this year I started to
pursue healing on my own shot her
childhood trauma I'm actually reading
this because I knew I had to read it you
got it you hate read it read away that's
cool
with that I've experienced depression
and time where I emotionally you know
pretty much checked out
um the area where I really struggle with
is in motherhood okay and if all times
get home mom I fear I've put trauma on
them
I take all their behavior issues or when
I feel they're hurting as my fault like
emotional and hurting or um when I see
the emotionally struggling
um and I find myself sometimes not
intervening
there are squabbles or fights because I
feel like I don't know what to do or I'm
just too exhausted to follow through I
just want to find my joy in motherhood
again okay when did you when did you
feel it leave
um probably after the second to youngest
how many do you have
four
how old are what's the oldest
eight eight seven six and one good
box of bananas that was me trying not to
swear I don't know where that
um
Caitlyn that's a whole whole lot
yeah
um tell me about this latest one
um was the latest one planned or was it
a hey look what we have here yes yeah
yes he was
yeah which one
yes okay all right
um so when when did what happened that
you suddenly felt the joy of motherhood
just leaving you
I guess I'm not sure
um I know after the second thing I
missed I did suffer from to postpartum
depression okay as well as with our
youngest but um yeah are you married
yes tell me about that
um he's a great guy I mean
yeah I love him he's he's a very very
awesome dad to the kids okay
tell me about your marriage
it's I mean I that's good I mean I mean
we definitely could improve on
connection on connecting with each other
better or or
um
um what's the word to use
like can um
I can't think of the word right now but
here's here's what happens often in the
situation you're describing is one
person is is either struggling or down
regulated a little bit or just feeling a
little bit heavy
and another the other partner steps in
and helps and is really wonderful and
it's both life-giving and it's a teeny
tiny bit
shameful like I I it's like I should be
doing that or how can he or she do that
and I just can't do it and that call
causes us to pull back a little bit more
and then that person fills in the Gap a
little bit more and suddenly we've
created a dance that's that's it's hard
we end up co-managing our household but
we're not we're great business partners
but we're not married
see what I'm saying and I'm not saying
that's happening that's what I'm trying
to get at has your body found yourself
surrounded by a whole bunch of people
and you are completely alone that's what
I'm getting at
uh-huh yeah yeah is that right okay tell
me about this childhood trauma you
experienced
um
um okay how old were you
um over a period years
when did it start
around the age of six or so okay
um
who is who's who is
who is the evil person in your life
my dad okay
I'm sorry
I know you know this but that shouldn't
happen I'm sorry
yeah yeah just this morning and as I was
writing out your question it came to me
about
could it be that I have fear
that I'm going to be hurting my kids as
well and I you know I don't know but
that's something that came to my mind
this morning as I was writing the
question out
um I think any of those things that pop
into your mind are worth asking
um
without meeting you this is total total
conjecture okay my guess is
um or if I was if I just met you we just
had the conversation we've had and I was
to place a bet my bet would be that your
body
has a recognized there's an eight and a
seven and a six-year-old in your home
and it recognizes that story
and
it'll be damned if it happens again and
it becomes hyper Vigilant all the time
in protection of those three little kids
and you put that level of
um say sympathetic arousal but you put
that level of a brain that is on high
alert high high high alert
and then you dump a one-year-old into
that
and then you dump right and you see what
I'm saying so all of a sudden your body
is vacillating between It's At War and
then it's got to shut the system down or
it's gonna crash and it's just this
constant toggle and it's hard to be in a
relationship with that kind of person
struggling that way and it's hard to be
in a relationship when you are
struggling that way and then you find
yourself more and more isolated yet more
and more busy and more and more lonely
surrounded by more and more people
and you feel like you're going insane
am I right or wrong tell me where I'm
right and tell me where I'm wrong
no yeah that that's about how it would
be okay
so the the magic is not the magic it's
not magic at all the gnarly gritty
healing work is letting your body feel
there's a six-year-old in the house
there's a seven-year-old there's an
eight-year-old in the house and
foreign
because they have me as their mom
and my my dad was the worst of the worst
of the worst but their dad is not
my dad was evil they're dead safe
and we're gonna practice feeling our
bodies when it starts to take off on us
on us and then we are going to practice
re-taking control of the thoughts that
we have
and then we're going to do the really
hard work which is
write data letter that you're never
going to send him
and let him know
how I hurt you and how that's ricocheted
through your life
you'll write another letter to him let
him know what he's missed
then you're going to write him another
letter that says hey by the way this
stopped here
because I've got four beautiful
incredible kids and I'm a damn good mom
and just to put a cherry on top I'm a
great wife too
I'm a good friend
see what I'm saying
yes yes and then you've got to do the
harder hard hard stuff which is you got
to take care of yourself you got to be
around people and you got to laugh and
you have to exercise and you got to
sleep and you got to eat right and you
have to give yourself some Grace because
you have a freaking one-year-old in your
in your house right which is like just
pulling a grenade every morning just
rolling it into the living room and
saying yeah let's see what explodes
today
how does that all sound sound like
bullcrap does it sound right what tell
me what you tell me what you're feeling
I don't know
I mean yeah
it all sounds good I mean I've been you
know working through this journey for
the past you know well beginning of the
year when I started
and um yeah
um
I'm gonna give you a really awful
analogy but it's the most recent one in
my life is that okay
yeah okay
um I was on a trip
um this past weekend with my son and
some men that I trust and love and their
boys and we went on this Texas hunting
trip and it's every bit if when you hear
the words Texas hunting trip it was all
of it okay
and the very first night the boy the old
men we were sitting on the on a rocking
chair out on the front porch of this
metal building in the middle of nowhere
no running water or anything and the
boys are running around with flashlights
being silly
and one of the boys trips on the fire
pit
and just blast his shin on it it
explodes
okay
um whenever we saw him in the light we
took him inside looked in the light and
the moment I saw it it's like some he's
got to go to the hospital right now
and it was a gnarly gnarly cut and his
dad I stayed with the boys his dad took
him to the emergency room with another
friend of ours
and in the ER
they took that cut and they gave him
some uh medicines that he couldn't feel
the pain
but then they had to take out this
sandpapery scrub brush
and clean the wound
and my buddy said he had to sit down and
he and because he started getting woozy
because it was an already violent scene
and it became the healing process the
initial healing was really brutal
okay
and then that allowed them to do the
first layer of stitches and then close
it up and then do the top layer of
stitches and within 24 hours that little
boy was running around again
when you're healing from trauma
the initial part of the journey is very
empowering I write these letters I feel
good like I feel like I'm taking control
I weep heavily I call family I call
friends I have this moments
and then we recognize how deep that
wound is and how much it's affected
other things
and then starts the grinding process the
real painful part the part where we wish
it hadn't happened and I can't believe
you did this and then I've made
decisions in my life out of pain out of
hiding out of fear and I've hurt people
and people have hurt me and and you've
got to get through that grinding
sandpaper process so that
healing can happen in a clean way on the
back end and that feels like where you
are and then you threw a one-year-old
baby in the middle of it all
all right which is just hard and then
you've got a six and seven eight year
old that's reminding your body what
you've been through before
and so that means this is front and
center here this isn't like you had
sexual childhood childhood sexual abuse
and you're single and you're 25 and
you're spending time with a therapist
and spending time in a group you spend
time with your friends you are living
this out you are changing the oil on
your car while you're driving
it's a very complex task that you've
undertaken and it's right
it's good it's just gonna be hard and
when it's hard and when it's messy when
you don't feel full like you're at the
very tip top your Tank's not full that's
okay
the person who should have taught you
that you're okay
took everything from you when you were a
kid
right
yeah and so now you've got to do the
hard work of relearning wait a minute
man I do have value I am worthy of being
loved
I am a good mom
you're not going to re-traumatize your
kids Hon you're just not
unless you abuse them what you're not
going to do no letting an eight and a
six and a seven-year-old squabble and
figure stuff out that's great
it's great I over get involved in my
kids
and every time I do it I think gosh I
just need to let them work this out
so you're doing great
I'd love to see you and your husband
um
take a marriage Retreat together just
you too get away for a weekend and
recalibrate because now you got four
humans that you're responsible for in
addition to yourself so your needs have
shifted your needs have changed your
life has changed your sleep is goofed up
your exercise is all good everything's
goofed up
and so it's not about trying to get back
to what was it's trying to create
something new and at the same time
you're becoming a different person
you're healing you're standing you're
going to stand six inches taller when
this thing's over
keep working with your counselor
keep hanging in there I'm gonna send you
all the questions for humans cards for
kids and I'm going to send you the
questions for humans cards for couples
here's what often happens when someone's
working through a trauma journey and
they're in a long-term relationship
they're married with somebody right or
they already have kids
the idea of human engagement is what
hurt you in the first place
the closest relationship your dad
that's a violation and it becomes this
awful thing where that's the thing
that's going to keep you well as
relationships with other people that's
where your body's gonna settle in so you
can do these other things like Eat Right
exercise sleep all that you you gotta
have that Foundation of being connected
and that's the that's the that's what
hurt you in the first place
and so it's hard to
start practicing being a relationship
again that's what these cards are for
deck cards and they're magic man
um so I'm going to send you everything I
got
um with those so you can do this with
your kids you can do this with your
husband y'all can get away for a minute
stay on the journey stay on the path you
are doing a great job your kids are
lucky to have you as their mother
and all of us are benefiting from your
bravery thank you for telling your story